the story that I'm going to tell you
today has to do with a beverage and its
many varieties namely beer and it begins
in my teenage years in the 80s and
extends all the way into about my late
30s I could say you could even say a
little bit beyond that not so much me
brewing beer at that point but helping
somebody else out with doing so and it's
something that I've considered going
back to before in the past probably
won't anytime soon but it's it's you
know something to kick around and so
what is what is this about well I got
into home brewing in the early 1990s and
then took it up again in the 2000s and
so I got to begin a little bit earlier
in the 1980s so you know I grew up here
in Wisconsin in the we could call it the
greater Milwaukee area and you know um
most of our parents drank beer of one
sort or another it was a very popular
beverage uh most of the beers that you'd
get at that time were what we call
American psers which are like psers but
considerably watered down right uh maybe
with decent amount of hops but not an
awful lot of body light beers were
becoming popular at the time as well
which even further watered things down
and there were a wide range of them I
mean tons of them were made here in
Milwaukee or in other parts of Wisconsin
Miller Genuine Draft came out while we
were in high school and that was our
favorite one to get our hands on you
know for parties and bonfires and
camping trips and all that sort of stuff
when of course we weren't of age to
drink but it was very you know
widespread and you could usually find
some sort of adult who would buy you
beer or you had had a friend who who
would get some and you know there were
there were quite a few occasions to do
that and so you would drink it and at
first it didn't taste that great but you
developed a taste for it fairly quickly
and that was our our our you know sort
of world we didn't know much about the
wide range of possible beers that you
could drink and then I went in the Army
and I got stationed in southern Germany
in uh not actually in a town but about 2
miles out of a town called
fuit and um my very first time out on
the economy as we called it meaning you
go go off a post friend of mine took me
to a restaurant and in addition to
having schnitzel which was awesome uh I
had Tu heiton and that was like a taste
Revelation to me I was like whoa this is
this is awesome stuff right and then
we'd drink all sorts of other beers as
well and sometimes you had friends who
actually lived on off post because they
were married and they would buy beer on
the economy and you can buy beer on post
as well you know at the PX or at the uh
I forget the name of the club that we
had on post and then of course there
were all sorts of bars everywhere and so
I I picked up a taste while I was over
in Germany for good beer you know I I
tried a lot of different types and then
I came back here to Wisconsin I got out
in the budget cuts in 1990 so I was only
20 years old when I got here and then
but you know most of my friends were
older cuz I hung out with an older crowd
and you know we started buying local
beers and and some International beers
and tasting them you know like Guinness
extra Stout and um you know we we had
the shreer brewery here which is one of
the first craft breweries in the United
States that was doing so commercial and
we had the black baravarian the Amber
and so these were were getting
introduced to cooler kinds of beer and
but by the time that I was in college
you had all sorts of interesting things
coming on the market Lon and cougal
which is a a Wisconsin brewery they had
brought out a couple different types so
we Hader L and cougal there was a
Killians which you know people were into
and there a whole bunch of others and
you could go to special grocery stores
or liquor stores and buy imported beer
right so you get bass pale ale and old
peculiar and all these these other cool
things
so that's going on and I'm in college by
now and um my sophomore year I was
living in what was called the Honors
Suite and it was four rooms together and
each one of us had an individual room
which was really great because I didn't
I I didn't like having a roommate and uh
you know you had a decent sized room
with a good
closet and I'm not sure exactly where I
got the idea I I think reconstructing it
it was probably that uh I picked up the
complete guide to home brewing at Walden
books because my my girlfriend at the
time was working there and read through
it and I was like I think I want to do
this so we we drove down to Milwaukee I
remember that and I remember going to
this um beer and wine making supply
store and they you know everything was
laid out you got the different packages
of uh malt and different HPS and
Specialty grains and all the things you
need to get started including like the
bottle you know cap thing that you you
have to put on there so I had to buy
everything at that time because I knew
it was going to be a while before I came
back down and in my dorm room not in
some big you know Kettle that I I used
later on but in a hot pot that I think
held only at best like you know maybe a
quart or a quart and a half um I I did
the laborious
process of boiling the Hops putting them
into the big you know uh essentially
white garbage bucket that you you use as
your primary
fermentor and then um you know boiling
what is called the wart which is the um
The Malt and the water and you got to be
really careful with that because it has
a tendency to boil over so you have to
watch it kind of like a hawk and turn
the stuff down and you know anyway a big
long process right and then it's it's in
this bucket and you add more water to it
and then you put the lid on and pretty
soon it starts
fermenting and then after that you got
to siphon it into this giant Carboy a
big glass thing with kind of a a smaller
lip on top and you put this seal on that
has like a little lock that the bubbles
can come out and stuff and there were
you know some kind of Misadventures with
this sometimes it's fermenting too quick
and the bubbles are you can see the Hops
coming up through the bubbles and stuff
like that and you could smell it and you
could hear it right this constant
bloooo as as it's going on I hid it in
my closet just so you know because you
weren't allowed to like ferment
beverages on campus anyway that that's
that's what I did and I did this you
know a couple times and brewed some
decent batches of beer I never had any
of them go bad on me or anything
and it was you know tasty stuff managed
to bottle them leave them for a while
let them ferment in the bottles then
pour it out and then my sweet mate Joel
hos got into it and he and I were
buddies in part because you know I was
ex Army he was ex Marines I knew his
sister Faith from having lived in the
French Suite with her the semester
before and you know we're very uh
compatible and he he liked beer too like
pretty much all of us and he was like
man I want to do this and he wanted to
get get a little bit more elaborate with
it you know and he actually did have one
batch that did go bad we had to pour it
out you know five gallons at a time
right but he wanted to do stuff like
logging and you know I stuck to alses
things that are pretty simple hard to
screw up he wanted to do more advanced
stuff and and I was like well that's
cool you know um you do your thing and
I'll do my thing and we'll swap back and
forth and he made he made some decent
beers and I made some decent beers as
well and this went on during that year
and then after a while I got kind of
tired of it and I was like this is a lot
of work you know I can just as easily
buy the beer that I want and I gave all
my equipment to to Joel and that was it
for a long long time you know I finished
undergraduate moved down here to
Milwaukee worked a year went to graduate
school and uh then after graduate
school I moved uh my my little family to
my big family's land in Indiana that
I've talked about in other videos and we
uh had Uncle Hubert and an Teresa's
house the house that um you know they
had had built in in the 1970s we took it
over and there was an an unfinished
basement but one that had a stove and a
sink and actually a big Locker that we
could we could put stuff in sort of like
a a wall Locker in the Army about six
feet high and I think about four feet
wide just big enough to put a lot of
cases of beer into right and so I deci
decided that I wanted to start home
brewing again I wanted to try it out I
wanted to be kind of a
Craftsman so I got myself a big you know
like cauldron and I went and purchased
the equipment again and by this time
there was a place that was fairly near
to where we lived and you know I would I
was working at Indiana State Prison at
the time which was an hour drive and I
could make a slight detour onto Route 6
and then there was a place that I could
go to and home brewing had Advanced
considerably since then so the kinds of
uh products that were available widened
all these cool specialty grains and
malts and then you know the regular
malts and all these different Hops and
so I started um I started
brewing and it went pretty good um you
know what you do what you know now I
could actually take a giant um Kettle
and um you know do the the um the malt
and I also did the high separately and
in like a big pan and or a pot rather
and what was really fun with this is I
actually brought my kid in my at that
time the only kid cat my oldest kid and
we had a great time uh cat would help me
you know it turned it into almost like
an apprenticing process and they don't
remember it uh because it was you know
quite a long time ago but you know cat
would help me measure out the the
different grains and put them into the
boiling water and you know smell the
Hops oh these these smell really spicy
right and it was like a whole process
that we did together for making the wart
and then the primary fermentation and
Cat would even help me sometimes with
siphoning you know into the secondary
fermentor or doing the putting it into
the bottles right and stuff like that
obviously cat wasn't going to be
drinking any of this sort of stuff stuff
but it was uh it was fun for us to do
anyway and um I you know bottled a lot
of beer enough to actually over time
fill up that whole wall Locker because
you can age beers and you can let them
sit for a while and not all of them
improve with that and you can't let it
like sit 5 10 years and hope that you're
going to have anything special happening
but you know a year or so sometimes it
really improves the bruise so you you
you make something and you're like m not
great let's let's put it in there for a
while and you know I was uh drinking
cases of beer or actually was buying
beer by the case I wasn't drinking like
a whole case in a day but I would you
know Buy Corona and I would buy backs
and a few other ones and then I would
use those bottles reuse the bottles
right um and uh you just buy bottle caps
and you got a bottle Capper and you put
them on and then uh make sure of of
course you label what the the beer is
and then I sat down just a bit earlier
to try to remember all the different
things that I actually made over the
years and I would you know kind of cycle
through these and try new things out so
I always loved India Pale alses I made
quite a few of those I also made pale
ale sort of like bass I made uh bitters
where it's a bit more hoppy you know but
not that high of an alcohol content I
made Brown alses where you you've got a
bit more dark malt and you know Crystal
malt and chocolate malt in there as well
I made a lot of Milds which are super
cheap and easy to make it's not very
alcoholic but it's got a good taste to
it you know uh I made quite a few Stouts
I was getting pretty good at that and I
even made quite a few Porters and a
porter is sort of like a stout except uh
think about even more going into it
they're expensive to make in part cuzz
lots of hops lots of specialty grain
lots of malt high alcohol content those
are the ones that you actually can age
for a while and they improve by the
aging process as I discovered when I
forgot about a whole bunch of Po uh
Porter in the bottom of the the locker
and then rediscovered it later on and
cracked it open and I was like holy crap
this is this is pretty amazing I also
made Mead uh just just as sort of an
experiment um never got really good at
me making but my my relatives liked it
I'd take it to the family reunion and
put it in the auction or things like
that it was always kind of a big draw
and then I made two interesting
specialty beers and I might have made
others but I couldn't remember if I'd
done any others so one you know Northern
Indiana lots and lots of blueberries so
I was like well let's do a blueberry
beer where I'll you know make a normal
beer but I'll add a whole bunch of
blueberries to it and of course it came
out purple uh and it was you know it was
okay and it was one of those things
where I was like let's put these aside
and about a year later it was pretty
awesome it had you know something had
happened and it turned out really good I
also experimented with uh Spruce beer
because we had a big spruce tree outside
and and Spruce is sort of like Pine it's
a conifer right and in the old days it
wasn't always hops that got used for the
bittering agent Spruce was sometimes
used for that as well so I made some
Spruce beer and it turned out pretty
good um you don't want to put too much
of the spruce needles in it right but it
was uh it was satisfactory and I would
share these with my uncles and you know
friends who came over and uh it was it
was a lot of enjoyment that I I took in
that and then um at a certain
point you know my my uncle's cousin was
getting into home brewing and I was
getting kind of bored with it after a
while I had other stuff I wanted to be
focusing on and so I gave my equipment
to to him and like told him gave him
some basic instructions on how to do it
and uh he took it from there uh and that
was it for me for home brewing for quite
a
while but I did in the um well while I
was down at fville State University from
2008 to
2011 I had a friend who was the chair of
the communications department and um I
think it was probably I want to say
about maybe
200 10 he started getting interested in
home brewing now he was going to do it
in a way that was much more intensive
where like you you don't just buy all
the stuff basically pre-road and stuff
like that he wanted to like get his own
grains and malt them and stuff like that
and I was like oh man that's that's a
lot of work but if you want to do it
more power to you um I don't know that
you're going to make that much of a
better beer as a result but hey you know
you got the time you got the place you
got the the space to do it you've got
the interest so go ahead and knock
yourself out and so I helped him out
with the first couple
batches in his kitchen uh not doing you
not doing the you know uh roast your own
grains or stuff like that just doing the
stuff you'd buy at the store and you
could buy it there locally in fville by
that time home brewing was very common
and uh you know stuff turned out good uh
and they kept on improving I think he
might still be doing it I don't know we
we've lost touch over the years but it
it's something that I really took some
enjoyment in you don't have to like be
super smart or super uh um ambitious or
anything to do a decent job making your
own beer and that's that's what I did it
was kind of something to do on the
weekends every once in a while uh and
you could take pride in your own work
and taste the uh the effects of what you
had done so I may get into it someday
down the line but probably not I'm I'm
content now actually I drink
non-alcoholic beers and there's so many
good ones out there that it's not really
uh hard to find them including many
versions of beers that I I like that are
now available you know Guinness has a a
great non-alcoholic version so does
Heineken um but it was a very
interesting and fun chapter of my life I
enjoyed the product an awful lot so I
thought I would uh share that little
story with
you